Et vous ne saviez pas vraiment
ce qui allait en être tiré.
SD : La technique que nous avons utilisée --
imaginez un miroir optique, brisez-le
et éparpillez les éclats à différents endroits.
Un miroir normal
a une surface parfaite qui réfléchit les rayons lumineux
afin de les concentrer sur un même point au même moment.
On prend tous ces enregistrements
et avec la précision d'une horloge atomique,
nous les alignons parfaitement, par la suite dans un supercalculateur.
Nous créons une lentille de la taille de la Terre.
Pour ce faire, on ne peut apporter les données que par avion.
On ne peut pas battre la capacité d'un 747 rempli de disques durs.
(Rires)
CA : Je suppose qu'il y a quelques semaines ou mois,
sur un écran d'ordinateur,
l'image a commencé à être visible.
Ce moment.
SD : En fait, ça a pris beaucoup de temps.
CA : Voici l'image.
C'était ça.
C'était la première image.
(Applaudissements)
Alors, dites-nous ce qu'on aperçoit vraiment.
SD : Je l'adore toujours.
(Rires)
Ce qu'on voit est la dernière orbite des photons.
La géométrie d'Einstein est révélée.
L'espace-temps est si profondément percé
que la lumière se déplace en orbite,
de telle sorte que la lumière de derrière que nous verrons bientôt,
contourne et arrive vers nous de manière parallèle,
exactement sur cette orbite.
Il s'avère que cette orbite est la racine carrée de 27
multipliée par quelques constantes fondamentales.
C'est extraordinaire quand on y pense.
CA : Quand...
Dans ma tête, au début, quand j'ai pensé aux trous noirs,
je voyais l'horizon des événements,
où beaucoup de matière et de lumière tourbillonnant de cette façon.
Mais c'est en fait plus compliqué que ça.
Parlez-nous donc de cette animation où la lumière est déviée par le trou noir.
SD : Ici, la lumière venant de derrière est déviée
et de la lumière fait une boucle autour de l'orbite du trou noir.
Mais en ayant assez de lumière
venant des gaz chauds tourbillonnant autour du trou noir,
on finit par voir tous ces rayons lumineux
arriver ensemble sur cet écran,
qui représente l'endroit où nous sommes.
Vous voyez donc comment cet anneau se forme.
C'est ce qu'Einstein avait prédit il y a plus de 100 ans.
CA : Oui, c'est incroyable.
Parlez-nous de ce qu'on est en train de regarder ici.
D'abord, pourquoi y a-t-il une partie plus lumineuse ?
SD : Alors, ce qu'il se passe, c'est que le trou noir tourne.
Ainsi, on se retrouve avec du gaz venant vers nous depuis le bas
et du gaz qui s'éloigne par le haut.
De la même manière que le son du train est plus aigu
quand il s'approche de nous,
le gaz fournit plus d'énergie lorsqu'il vient vers nous.
La partie inférieure est plus claire
parce que la lumière est en fait accélérée dans notre direction.
CA : Est-ce grand physiquement ?
SD : Notre système solaire peut s'insérer dans cette région sombre.
Si je peux me permettre,
cette région sombre est la signature de l'horizon des événements.
On ne voit pas la lumière venant de là-bas,
car la lumière censée venir de cet endroit
a été avalée par l'horizon des événements.
Alors c'est... c'est tout.
CA : Et en imaginant un trou noir,
on voit ces énormes rayons qui en sortent,
qui pointent dans notre direction.
Pourquoi ne les voit-on pas ?
SD : C'est un trou noir très puissant.
Pas selon les normes universelles, mais il est tout de même puissant
et nous pensons que des jets sortent des pôles nord et sud de ce trou noir,
Nous sommes trop proches pour vraiment voir la structure du jet
mais c'est la base de ces jets qui illuminent l'espace-temps.
C'est ce qui est dévié autour du trou noir.
CA : Et si on tournait autour dans un vaisseau spatial,
combien de temps faudrait-il pour faire le tour ?
SD : Je donnerais tout pour être dans ce vaisseau.
(Rires)
Inscrivez-moi.
Il y a quelque chose qui s'appelle -- si je peux me permettre --
la dernière orbite circulaire stable.
C'est l'orbite la plus profonde où la matière peut se déplacer
avant qu'elle ne descende en spirale.
Pour ce trou noir, elle dure entre trois jours et environ un mois.
CA : C'est tellement puissant que c'est étrangement lent.
Je veux dire, on ne remarquerait même pas
si l'on y était et si l'on tombait dans cet horizon des événements.
SD : Connaissez-vous la « spaghettification » ?
En tombant dans un trou noir,
le champ gravitationnel à vos pieds est beaucoup plus fort qu'à votre tête,
on est donc déchiré.
Ce trou noir est tellement grand
qu'on ne pourrait pas se transformer en spaghetti.
On dériverait uniquement à travers l'horizon des événements.
CA : C'est comme une tornade géante.
Quand Dorothy a été aspirée par une tornade, elle a fini à Oz.
Où est-ce qu'on finit si l'on tombe dans un trou noir ?
(Rires)
SD : Vancouver.
CA : Oh, mon Dieu.
(Applaudissements)
C'est le cercle rouge, c'est terrifiant.
Non, vraiment.
SD : Les trous noirs sont vraiment le mystère central de notre époque,
car c'est là que le monde quantique et le monde gravitationnel se rejoignent.
A l'intérieur, il y a une singularité.
C'est là où toutes les forces s'unissent,
parce que la gravité est enfin assez forte pour rivaliser avec les autres forces.
Mais elle nous est cachée,
l'univers l'a occultée dans la cape d'invisibilité ultime.
On ignore ce qu'il se passe là-dedans.
CA : Il y en a un plus petit dans notre propre galaxie.
Pouvons-nous revenir à notre belle galaxie ?
C'est la Voie lactée, chez nous.
Au milieu de tout ça, il y a un trou noir,
que vous essayez de trouver aussi.
SD : Nous savons déjà qu'il est là et nous avons déjà des données.
Nous travaillons sur ces données en ce moment même.
Nous espérons bientôt avoir quelque chose, je ne saurais pas dire quand.
CA : Il est plus proche mais aussi plus petit,
peut-être la même taille que celui observé ?
SD : C'est vrai, le trou noir de M87,
qu'on a vu avant,
est de six milliards et demi de masses solaires.
Mais il est si loin qu'il apparaît d'une certaine taille.
Le trou noir au centre de notre galaxie est mille fois moins massif
mais aussi mille fois plus près.
Leur taille angulaire dans le ciel est donc similaire.
CA : Enfin, je suppose, un clin d'œil à un groupe remarquable.
Qui sont ces gens ?
SD : Ce ne sont que quelques-uns des membres de l'équipe.
Nous sommes émerveillés de l'écho que cette image a engendré.
Si vous m'aviez dit que ce serait à la une de tous les journaux,
je ne suis pas sûr que j'y aurais cru, mais ça l'était.
Parce que c'est un grand mystère
qui est inspirant pour nous et j'espère, pour tout le monde.
Mais le plus important, c'est que ce n'est qu'un petit nombre de l'équipe.
Nous sommes 200 personnes dans 60 instituts
et 20 pays et régions.
Pour construire un télescope mondial, il faut une équipe mondiale.
Cette technique que nous utilisons pour relier des télescopes du monde entier
met de côté sans effort les problèmes qui nous divisent.
Pour les scientifiques, il est naturel de s'unir pour réaliser cela.
CA : Diantre, c'est inspirant pour toute notre équipe cette semaine.
Shep, merci beaucoup pour votre travail et votre venue.
SD : Merci.
(Applaudissements)